[Music]
[Applause]
there's a few fan bases that feel pretty
good today in theory
because it's like spring training this
is football's version of spring training
we got hope we got a chance
the sun is out if you're a jets fan
you're like yes giants fan yes
eagles fan yes
we don't want to start positive do we
with dan arlovsky of the mothership kind
enough to join us uh it looks like he's
outside a hotel here uh you can see him
on nfl live later today three to five
eastern on uh the mothership dan do you
want to start positive or negative
i'll start positive i have to it's
friday morning i'm outside caesar's
palace uh waiting for my ride not the
real one dan
um i will say
jets had a franchise-changing draft okay
um just just a phenomenal draft for them
um when when you talk about
the talent that they got is just
lights out um jermaine johnson
um gary wilson i had said yesterday dan
i would have taken garrett wilson with
the number one pick if i was the jaguars
i think he's going to be that bit of a
wide receiver in the nfl
i think he's devante adams yeah and
that's where the league is going
obviously we saw the trades uh
philadelphia had an incredible evening
um and
is is the division favorite uh in the
nfc east
um i thought the giants got a lot better
in the line of scrims
the detroit lions
are the second best team in that
division right now
um so some really really good starts for
teams
uh
we waited for pittsburgh to take can he
pick it were you uh how surprised at
that
i wasn't shocked that the quarterback i
just thought at 20 if malik willis was
there they were gonna take malik willis
um listen awesome phenomenal story when
it comes to kenny pickett and and him
being from there and then playing card
football in there and
i have a couple things number one they
see candy pick it every day pittsburgh
that organization they practice
basically on the same fields so
they've obviously got to feel
a level of comfort with uh the selection
of him
um
he's a very similar player to mitchell
chris you know and that's where i have a
little bit of hesitation with it is
um physically they're kind of the same
guy good athlete really dependent on
their ability to run around and create
um
for mechanically
average accuracies so i feel that that's
why i felt a little bit stronger about
if they get a guy malik was because of
the high-end talent or at desmond ritter
because of his
you know is a pocket
operation um but
yeah like i said they see kenny pickett
every day so they must really like them
yeah and we've corresponded i don't
think any of these quarterbacks are
first-round talents um
right i think they're all projects i
just brought up if i'm a team and i and
i need a quarterback now
i take baker mayfield i somehow make a
deal for baker mayfield it's a one-year
deal dan and if the browns will pick up
the tab or half of it i got a starting
quarterback for 18 million dollars who
now needs to prove himself
you know a guy who plays with a chip on
his shoulder man i'd be i'd be really
interested in baker mayfield right now
than one of these guys who are going to
be a project who are going to be drafted
you know either tonight or tomorrow
yeah no-brainer dan i said that he'll be
the draft steal of the weekend
and if you're the team here's the
reality because it's facts over feelings
the fact is the last time baker mayfield
uh played healthy in the nfl 21 of 30
320 yards against the kansas city chiefs
now yes he threw an interception on the
final game-winning drive potential
but he played really good football that
day two years ago in 2020 the top 10
players so is your vantage point 2020 or
2021 um with how you view baker mayfield
but if i'm one of these teams and i'm
sitting here and i get into the fourth
round cleveland's gotta eat 14 15
million dollars of this deal because if
they cut them they got to pay them 19.
so they got to eat a chunk of it and
that's their own doing but if you're in
the fourth round and you wanted to drop
the quarterback and you can get baker
mayfield and here's the truth baker
mayfield has had better seasons in the
nfl than daniel jones than marcus
mariota than chuatanga vialoa i mean
he's had just as good of a season as
ryan tannehill
the indianapolis colts matt ryan's had
one better season than him and now he's
had a lot more consistency but
um i just think
he'll be a steal a draft for some gm
we're talking to dan olofsky joining us
from outside caesar's palace there help
me understand lamar jackson he sends out
the tweet wtf when hollywood brown gets
traded now he's followed up by saying
hey that tweet was not about us drafting
a center
uh stop that bs so what what is the wtf
uh i i think there's some some hurt
there you know hollywood hammer boys i
mean they kind of grew up in the same
area and and it's bigger than football
for lamar when it comes to hollywood and
the fact that hollywood went to the
organization asked for the trade and
really
at least to our reports today did not
communicate in any way to lamar that i i
think he's hurt over that you know he
lost a good receiver but i think he lost
one of his best friends and i think
that's where that frustration lies the
ravens had an incredible draft
it's just this is going to be
overshadowing it and then the second
thing too dan is you know they're in
contract negotiations with him so
um
you know the fact that his best friend
or one of his best friends didn't tell
him this and then the organization
didn't in any way
hint to it um we could have probably
seen the writing on the wall or the tea
leaves when it comes to all the
receivers that they have drafted over
the past couple years
uh but i think lamar is a little bit
more hurt than anything
help me understand what the titans you
know i know that they didn't want to pay
aj brown but you know this is a kid
who's 24 years of age
yeah uh i think this is all butterfly
effects from tyreek hill you know i said
when tyreek hill got traded from the
chiefs it was going to be nfl changing
because
teams are going to start to sit there
and go and all these
in the um
last four drafts so not including last
night there have been 40
receivers drafted in the first or second
round there's six of them that are no
greater busts
so the receivers that are coming into
the nfl
are now better players and more ready to
go in impactful guys early than guys of
the past so i think that's number one
obviously the kc trader tiger kill
the ability to acquire more kicks for
your roster number two
they think they believe that treylon
burks is gonna be a
you know plug and play type of performer
impactful why so i think that's the
biggest part of why and then
ryan daniels got the highest kept salary
out of any quarterback in the nfl this
year yeah and i think that's a little
bit of it as well
well i know you're busy man uh we
appreciate you joining us uh as always
and uh you'll have more of dan on nfl
live later on today at uh three to five
eastern thank you dan
thanks daniel the best bud uh dan
orlovsky espn
football analyst there joining us on his
way to i think first take